um other police over sharing
well you can understand why people are
saying that good morning Kay
um I don't think I've ever seen such a
level of detail released before
um there were various ways they could
have said that yesterday without
completely destroying uh Nicholas
reputation to be frank
and you have to ask why are they doing
that now if they'd release that on day
one it would have completely changed the
dynamic and
the coverage of this story and perhaps
prevented it becoming the jugular
Juggernaut story it now is so I'm
confused why they've done what they've
done now
you could understand why some people are
saying it's victim blooming to protect
their own reputation
I can't see how it progresses the case
any further forwards three weeks in to
be frank
um we'll have to wait to see but
um I've got to say this case more than
any other missing person case I've been
enrolled with over the years has
constantly LED back to alleged Mistakes
by the police themselves
reports of concern for welfare the
police went to the house two weeks
before that sort of information as well
would suggest a different line of
inquiry surely
it worked and equally because it says it
was a police car with police and mental
health professionals or health
professionals what that the subtext to
that is that this was a mental health
car uh and clearly this wasn't a
domestic abuse scenario or a drunken
person scenario it was a mental health
incident which Nicola was suffering
um that is crucial really I'm amazed it
hasn't been released before and of
course on February the 3rd in their
press conference they hadn't held many
um and that's February the first com
third conference they actually said
there were no significant issues
involving Nicholas health so they they
haven't released it then I could
understand in some ways why it is
completely destroying her reputation
it's a big move to take but if you're
not going to take it at the beginning of
the inquiry why now do it I don't
understand
yeah why why might they do you think um
it is to protect their reputation
well there's a lot of commentators this
morning saying it's to protect that
reputation Lancashire police haven't
come out of this inquiry well whilst
there's clearly some really dedicated
and competent professionals trying to
find Nicola the media strategy and the
media team in this inquiry are
definitely lacking and I've never seen
such poor middle handling and that's why
this story has become the story it has
because they are they didn't hold a
press conference or they held a press
conference and what they said at the
press conference was questionable
yeah um do you think the police should
be releasing their working hypotheses um
a former peer of yours um
a former detective Chief Inspector
saying and that this is not the thing to
do
I don't agree with that
um in Sarah Payne we had nine hypotheses
as to what happened to Sarah
sadly one of them was that she'd been
kidnapped by a stranger and that's what
happened in this scenario there's seven
hypothesis and and you cannot
expect the public to get behind you and
help you solve the case if you don't
tell them what you think has happened so
I don't agree with my piano I think work
working hypothesis helps the public
understand the situation helps the
family understand the situation and also
helps the public understand why the
police do what they do
um what isn't helpful is when the
hypothesis changes three weeks in and
arguably this whole story and this whole
strategy to find Nicola would have been
completely different if we've known this
on day one
do you have a view on what's happened to
her
I haven't actually I have a completely
open mind unusually normally I I look at
stuff and think oh but that's what's
happened but I don't know what's
happened
um
I honestly don't know what's happened
um if she has gone in the river she
could turn up within another six or
seven weeks in the RSC uh hopefully that
isn't the case but I don't know what's
happened the the mobile phone is still
on uh A team's call is the thing that
keeps coming back to me as to is there
someone else involved in this it's
extremely odd for someone to fall in the
river or
a river
um when they're still in the middle of a
phone call so that is the one that keeps
confusing me and keeps leading me back
to is there someone else involved
um hopefully one day we'll find out but
I've got to say Lancashire police were
very critical yesterday of all of the
tick tockers and the armchair sleuths
who were
um basically take up all their time but
actually they have appeared in this
inquiry in unprecedented volume because
the police didn't talk
um we've gone over a week without a
press conference because they're not
filling that space other people are so I
I am very critical of an action police I
think their media strategy has been poor